since you've had the mullet for a long
time
it seems like you are pretty on trend
with hair and beauty
um so i was wondering how long do you
think it's going to last and what do you
think is going to be the next big thing
when it comes to hair whether it be male
or female do you think everybody is
going to shave their heads do you think
it's going to be a half and half
situation
or do you think everybody's just have
nice long hair
okay well i appreciate the question here
nicole or nice soul
here's what i will will say is that i
will say that i have had this haircut
long before anybody else had it long
before riff raff
long before morgan wallin long before
um countless lesbians
okay uh rihanna everybody i will say
i've had it
long before
um and i think the trend the next thing
is going to be i think a shaved head but
with a
a cap of some sort
that has an electrical field that comes
out of it like a hologram type of field
where you can create whatever hairstyle
you want
and upload it to your head
so you can actually create
something thick or
thin or long or straight and i think
that that's probably
30 years off no i bet we're 15 years off
from that maybe less even
but that's where i see hair going
um that's what i see i see hair going
there with an
actual skin like a a layer a thing that
you put onto your head
and you wear you upload your style
so you could go raggedy and you could go
you could go uh
you know thug you could go banker
um you could go
you know uh balding one day
i mean you could meet a girl one day and
she's fine as hook and the next day she
needs keeps
so it could be anything it's possible
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one
you